No. I was thinking about man, these chicks on Instagram.
That just like post, basically this hookery.
Look, if you're a hook, if you're,
if you're trying to get followers as a chick and you're just posting your body
and your rump make no mistake, no bones about it.
Yuck and K followers is the new currency.
You've probably said that before to your friends. If it's the new currency,
then if you're posting your rump for followers, yuck. All right.
And that's it. Hey, guess what we're done with the combo? Cause there's no,
there's no rebuttal because that's what it is. Congratulations.
Um, I mean, dude,
what I want to know is who's taking it these pictures. If you're a guy,
I saw a video on Instagram the other day where,
um, uh, the, the, they were,
the guide showed the guy, he was out running Canyon. He was at,
I can't remember. Who's, she's a fan of the podcast. I know too.
And she was showing the video. She was, she caught this guy,
like videoing this girl while she was twerking
on Runyon Canyon. And this dude was like, all you dude.
When my dad used to take pictures of, of like our family on, on vacation,
he would do it. So, like he would be, he had the camera and he would be like,
he would be like this, like a,
like one time we were on a gondola and he was trying to not fall over into the
into the ocean. And he was just taking a picture like this.
And my brother was like, what a? And we were laughing and he got a good shot,
but he was still a. But dude, the more like you look when you take a photo,
the better the photo comes out and you know it. So that's the thing.
These dudes are taking pictures of their girlfriends that are,
you know, to get them more followers. And dude,
they look like man.
And these girls like, dude,
there was this one where this girl was like eating a sandwich that was like big
and the sandwich meat and the lettuce was all fallen out and it was so
goofy. She's just a silly girl.
She's just a silly girl with a crop top on,
let Mayo spill out of that sandwich.
What a silly girl, dude.
How do you get so silly?
Wait, I'm not done with the sentence.
Yo Harker period, dude.
So she's eating it. And it was like, and this guy's taking the,
and there was another, there was another post of hers way down.
And she was like, you know, being so silly, eat another thing. Oh,
it's always always about food. Oh wow. I mean a soup. Look at this.
My eyes are up to the right because you can.
That's what you do when a food is so good. You put your eyes up to the right.
You cute mother. Be rag
free conch. You can do whatever you want. But do me a quick favor.
Take a step out of the doorway.
Good gun dude.
So this girl was like swipe left for video
video of you eating a sandwich.
Hey,
Hucker breaking bad is a show.
I'll watch that. Hey. Oh,
swipe left. Because you want me to watch you eat a
Turkey sandwich? Hey,
Hucker game of Thrones is starting soon.
Dude.
There are shows where dragons ignite
and army.
And you want me to watch it?
Tally and dressing. Go in your mouth.
Hey Hucker there's a four-hour
documentary on Michael Jackson, licking little boys.
Anuses.
[Inaudible].
Cry, harder.
Develop a talent also.
Dude's who are following these crops.
Top.
I am starting the unfollowing.
That's what I'm starting. It's a hashtag.
And it's called V unfollowing. Okay.
When you see a girl with her eyes up to the right,
because she's eating some soup,
Hashtag it,
the unfollowing and you don't follow
these hookers or you ask for their Venmo and you
send them money, but you don't follow a man.
This is the unfollowing.
Okay.
You see a girl in a crop top.
Be in silly on a tricycle with our tuts.
That comment, the unfollowing hashtag it.
That's the new, bro. Why are we pretending? Like,
why are we pretending? Like this is a job.
Yeah.
In the car, dude. Where are we going? Doesn't matter. I got it.
Open the windows.
Dry by [inaudible].
I'm 38 dude. Come on man.
Swipe left to watch me eat a clunky sandwich.
Uh.
Come on man. I'm turning the fan on. Cause we getting hot up in this.
It's a Dyson Dude.
It's so insane. Dude. Swipe left to watch me to sandwich.
Have you heard of Tony soprano?
Yeah. Okay.
I'll throw my phone off a ski lift dude.
I'll go skiing to throw my phone off the ski lift.
For that.
The unfollowing man.
And if you're a dude taking pictures like this for your girl, take a hike, bro.
Put a vest with a bunch of pockets on, get a stick, whittle it down,
make it three feet. Get to step in.
Only walk on rocks, man, because you're a take a hike,
Push through green brush. You understand me bro?
Be a mad,
At least make fun of her when you're doing it. Like, what the are you doing?
What is this? You know? I mean,
I could never date somebody like that. Also. You're trying to get them like,
I don't know. You know, you don't have to get a man,
but if you're a lot of girls, they want to find a guy, you know,
you're not going to find the guy you want. If that's the you're posting, dude,
I'm not talking about like model shots.
If you're taking a picture of, of your up against a wall, just chill,
you know like this and your arms are behind your back and your old oiled up and
you got your, you know, and your, your mouth's open.
That's fine. That's a business. You're a model.
And but these models will also do the hook ins. They'll do the hook ins dude,
They'll eat sandwiches on a couch. Like it's silly.
It's nothing silly about eating a food Is what we got to do to live.
What the is silly about that. If that's silly breathing silly, make a post hook,
make a post where you're just, how about this breathing? Here's me breathing
now. crazy silly. Am I am breathing. Love reading
The unfollowing. I'm telling you, dude, get out there, get out there cult.
This is a issue, dude.
Get out there and, and start the unfollowing.
Um.
There's a problem, dude. It's a, it's a big problem. Like MTV was a big problem.
When that came out, man, I'm not even going to get into that.
That's just how I feel. And I don't feel like explaining it.
It doesn't matter.
man.